[Music]
when sex in the city came out in 1998
collective jaws dropped at its frankness
before then sex on tv tended to be from
a male gaze and was well a bit
unrealistic
this was four single women openly
talking about either wanting it or
having it
now two decades later they're at it
again
if you have good friends in your corner
anything's possible to get fans in the
mood in london tickets to see a pop-up
recreation of carrie's apartment sold
out in 24 hours
the thing about sets in the city is that
at the time it felt incredibly
emancipating and it really was but if
you watch some of those episodes again
there are some questionable issues the
very affluent almost entirely white
circles that they move in the gay
stereotypes not to mention the
occasionally questionable views on
sexual consent
starring in a one-woman show off
broadway real-life carrie bradshaw
candice bushnell whose book the series
was based on says its message wasn't
very feminist in the end
that time
was a very unfeminist time if you
remember there were so many actresses
who were saying i'm not a feminist
so
when
money is free-flowing there's less
feminism
when money's tighter and women have to
work and can't rely on men so much
there's feminism
as well as a new name the new series has
been given awoke makeover with racially
diverse friends even a non-binary
character i think that's why it's so
important they kind of tread lightly and
um to make sure that the storyline kind
of covers you know current times and
also is relatable as well because
not just the old friends will be
watching will be introduced to a new
range of audiences
the future is unwritten because we're
all at different stages of life
so what can we expect from this next
chapter well while sets in the city was
revolutionary in terms of how young
sexually active women were depicted on
tv don't rule out the reboots doing the
same for another group that's rarely
represented on screen women in their 50s
hello lovers
so hold on to your cosmos casey spencer
sky news